let me start by reiterating that I'm
pleased that the New York prosecution is
going forward they brought these charges
based on new evidence against Jeffrey
Epstein who is now a registered sex
offender and this is a very very good
thing his acts are despicable and the
eart prosecution offers an important
opportunity to more fully bring Epstein
to justice
in 2008 a major newspaper described the
obscene prosecution like this a florida
grand jury that is a grand jury convened
by the district attorney of Palm Beach
County had charged Epstein with the
lesser offense at that time the Epstein
legal team was elated he would have
avoided prison altogether but then the
United States Attorney's Office in Miami
became involved Epstein got an ultimatum
plead guilty to a charge that would
require jail time and registration or
face federal charges and that was the
week more than 10 years ago that Epstein
went to jail times have changed and
coverage of this case has certainly
changed since that article facts are
important and facts are being overlooked
this matter started as a state matter
who is prosecuted initially by the state
of Florida and not by the US Attorney's
Office in 2006 a grand jury convened by
the state attorney the District Attorney
of Palm Beach County reviewed the
evidence and recommended a single charge
and that charge would have resulted in
no jail time at all no registration as a
sexual offender and no restitution to
the victim further the State Attorney's
Office allowed Epstein to self surrender
and arraigned him the following morning
simply put the Palm Beach State
Attorney's Office was ready to let
Epstein walk free no jail time
nothing prosecutors in my former office
found this to be completely unacceptable
and they became involved our office
became involved our prosecutors assist
2008 article recounts presented the
ultimatum plead guilty to more serious
charges charges that required jail time
registration and restitution or we'd
roll the dice and bring a federal
indictment without the work of our
prosecutors Epstein would have gotten
away with just that state charge now
many today questioned the terms of that
ultimatum what's called the non
prosecution really good prosecutor will
tell you that these cases are complex
especially when they involve children
and even more so in 2006 I've shared
with those in this room today and will
make available publicly an affidavit
filed by the career prosecutor in a
civil matter related to the Epstein case
she talks about the challenges faced she
talks about the victims being scared and
traumatized refusing to testify and how
some victims actually exonerated pesty
most said significant concerns about
their identities being revealed the acts
that they had faced were horrible and
they didn't want people to know about
them and she goes on to write that quote
after the fact people allege that
Epstein would have been easily convicted
as the prosecutor who handled the
investigation she says in this affidavit
these contentions overlooked the facts
that existed at the time her description
of these facts are corroborated by the
FBI case agent
affidavit I've also shared today
thousands of prosecutors around the
nation this week are weighing guilty
pleas versus trials these cases have I
said or heart they require prosecutor to
ask whether it plea that guarantees jail
time and guarantees registration to ask
whether that flee versus going to trial
how do you weigh those two if going to
trial is viewed as the roll of the dice
the goal here was straightforward put
Epstein behind bars ensured he
registered as a sexual offender provide
victims with the means to seek
restitution and protect the public by
putting them on notice that a sexual
predator was in their midst this case
people have said was unusual and it was
it was complicated by the fact that this
matter started as a state investigation
a state grand jury brought that single
completely unacceptable charge a state
official allowed Epstein to self
surrender and so it is unusual because
it's unusual for a federal prosecutor to
intervene in a state matter such as this
we've seen cases recently different set
of facts different I don't want anyone
to see them comparing these cases but
we've seen other cases where state
prosecutors let both go with no sentence
and people shake their heads in this
case the federal office intervened
before the plea was taken and said stop
because if that plea is taken at the
state level you're gonna face serious
federal issues today we know a lot more
about how victims trauma impacts
their testimony and this too is
important our juries are more accepting
of contradictory statements
understanding that trauma impacted
memories work differently and today our
judges do not allow victim shaming by
defense attorneys
I have viewed the victim interviews
they're hard to watch because I know
that my former colleagues the men and
women of my office wanted to help I
wanted to help that is why we intervened
and that's what the prosecutors of my
office did they insist that go to jail
and put the world on notice that he was
and is a sexual predator Babson's
actions absolutely deserve a stiffer
sentence for years there been rumors of
investigations in other jurisdictions
and he should be prosecuted in any state
in which he committed a crime if there
are other states in which he committed
crimes if there other states that can
bring state charges they should consider
those as well
and so I absolutely welcomed this New
York prosecution it is the absolutely
right thing to do and I'm happy to take
questions
Eric Eric
how would you describe your relationship
with the president the news cycle here
with AB Steen is changing that my
relationship with the president's
outstanding he has I think very publicly
made clear that that I've got his
support he spoke yesterday in the Oval
Office
he and I have spoken let me add I keep
reading about articles about my
relationship with me and mr. Mulvaney
and he called me this morning to say
fast that our relationship is excellent
- and that any articles to the contrary
are in his words BS and and so it's I'm
here I'm defending this case that's my
job Thomas ABC News secretary a lot of
people are watching this news conference
including several young women who say
they were teenagers when Jeffrey Epstein
sexually assaulted them
they say they went to you looking for
help and they didn't hear back from you
until it was too late do you owe them an
apology so you're raising the issue of
the victim notification and in the
documents that I've circulated I've
addressed the issue of victim
notification as well the career
prosecutor in this case had a difficult
decision and she didn't make it alone
she made it in consultation with the FBI
and she made it in consultation with the
office the agreement that had been
negotiated had an unusual provision even
though this was a state case the victims
would have the opportunity to receive
restitution Epstein would be required to
pay for them to hire a lawyer to bring a
case against him a case in which you
would have to plead no contest and
provide them with restitution and the
concern and these are the words of the
career prosecutor that quote she did not
want to share with the victims that the
office was attempting to secure for them
the ability to obtain monetary
compensation because she is aware that
if she disclosed that and the
negotiations fell through
Epstein's counsel would use this to
question the victims credibility and her
concerns were not hypothetical
what if Epstein's attorneys had already
asked one of the victims quote now tell
me about when the federal prosecutors
told you about getting money and so when
the agreement was signed shortly after
the agreement was
Epstein's counsels indicated that
Epstein may not comply with the
agreement and the agreement was appealed
at various levels within the Justice
Department and she details from this
affidavit an affidavit that's also
corroborated by the FBI case agent how
she and he and the office was concerned
that Epstein might not comply and we
would have to go to trial and we had to
weigh the issue of how much to disclose
against the issue of the would we have
to go to trial we want to win we want to
put Epstein away and talking about this
would allow him to make the argument at
trial that their testimony was
compromised and so when she was finally
when it was finally clear that Epstein
would comply with the agreement she
talks about how she made efforts to
notify the victims how that was a Friday
afternoon at 4:15 and that she learned
that the state had scheduled the plea
for 8:30 the fallen Monday and she talks
about how over the weekend she made
every effort to notify the victims
so again I would refer you to the
documents I provided there is a big gulf
between sufficient evidence to go to
trial and sufficient evidence to be
confident in the outcome of that
troglytes and so so if I couldn't I'll
give you a follow up in there but if I
could and so when this case and I
provided a letter that outlines some of
the timeline of this in July of 2007 the
career staff from my office met and they
said these are the four points that you
will have to do in state court and if
not we will proceed federally they were
very serious that they would proceed
federally that does not mean that they
were confident in the final outcome and
one of the tough questions in these
cases what is the value of a secured
guilty plea with registration versus
rolling the ducks and I know that in
2019 looking back on 2008 things may
look different but this was the judgment
of prosecutors with dozens of years of
if you look through that letter you'll
see this was not a single person making
those decisions
I I do not think that the office
violated the ABA standards by
negotiating strongly and forcefully
thing you could you've got the best deal
you could get and you have no regrets we
believe that we proceeded appropriately
that based on the evidence and not just
my opinion that I've shared the
affidavit based on the evidence there
was value to getting a guilty plea and
having him registered look no regrets is
a very hard question at my confirmation
hearing I was asked a similar question
one of the one of the issues that I
raised as we expect a lot more
transparency today as you watch these
victim interviews it's very obvious that
the victims feel that this was not a
sufficient outcome these victims were
traumatized we can't begin to understand
what they went through and they look at
this and they say but why and so you
always look back and you say what if
what I can say is at the time and I've
provided a timeline of provided
information about the individuals
involved this was the view of the office
there is a value to a shirred guilty
plea because letting him walk letting
what the state attorney was ready to do
go forward would have been absolutely oh
yes Ben Tenn from Bloomberg law you know
in light of the attention this week on
on your handling of its back in 2008
victims of sex trafficking I wanted to
ask about your role today as a late
Secretary of Labor you have oversight
through the wage and hour division of
certifying visas for victims of human
trafficking including sex trafficking
and just last week er wage and hour
division issued a new policy that would
essentially allow the agency it's being
criticized by a lot of people I've
talked to you for allowing the agency to
completely remove itself or to virtually
remove itself from continuing to certify
these visas by referring them how can
you what was the purpose of that so so
that that is if you read the policy that
is not what it does our wage and hour
administrator after she was confirmed
came in and she reviewed the policies
and she put in place a requirement that
a criminal prosecutor be consulted any
time one of these issues is brought to
the divisions attention and that seems
very reasonable don't we want criminal
prosecutors to be consulted
whenever someone says that they are a
victim of trafficking and that
prosecutor will be consultant and even
if that prosecutor says this is not a
case that we are going forward with the
division will still consider whether to
issue that these on the facts so that is
a mischaracterization of her decision
and her policy
about where and how you exactly
negotiated this deal did you meet with
Epstein's attorney alone at a Marriott
Hotel so you know I've read this and one
of the things I find interesting is how
how facts become facts because they're
in a newspaper as opposed to the record
I pulled up I I found out the details of
that meeting because I scratched my head
about it and I've provided you a time
line in a letter of the negotiations
that make it very clear that this was
negotiated bacteria prosecutors the I'm
gonna answer your question the meeting
that was alleged was a breakfast meeting
that took place after the agreement was
negotiated not before the agreement was
signed in September after the agreement
was negotiated one of epson's attorneys
asked for a meeting asked for a hearing
I was giving a speech I was staying at a
hotel I agreed to have a brief meeting I
believe at 7:00 a.m.
rather than open the office I spoke with
that attorney and then I referred that
attorney to the career prosecutors
nothing changed in that agreement they
continue to litigate the matter they
continue to peel the matter to
Washington and nothing changed with one
one exception there was an addendum that
made clear that Epstein had to pay for
any attorney that a victim that
represented a victim in the cases
against Epstein and so yes I met with
opposing counsel it was a breakfast
meeting because I was staying at the
hotel it was after after not before and
not part of the negotiations but it was
after the agreement had to negotiate and
that can be confirmed simply by looking
at the date on the agreement and the
date on the meeting
[Music]
so number one the agreement had already
been locked in place so the agreement
wasn't going to change before that
agreement you know I was very careful to
not negotiate this our career attorneys
negotiated the agreement secondly I
point out we live in a city where people
have breakfast meetings all the time you
don't open an office at seven o'clock in
the morning just to have a meeting you'd
have it over breakfast let me let me let
me do this I I had I'd called you and
I'll come back to you I'll come back to
you
I I wanted to get me in an opportunity
I'm back to you in a minute thank you
sir you've mentioned several times that
you and the prosecutors in your office
weren't sure that you could secure a win
in this case but the very purpose of the
of the CVRA is to give the victims an
opportunity to weigh in and a federal
judge ruled that you broke federal law
by not doing so do you think that your
thinking would have been different had
you followed the law and consulted the
victims so first let me let me point out
we follow department policy department
policy at the time made very clear and
this is an irritant statement that was
subsequently issued by what is called
the office of legal counsel which is the
chief policy making the chief legal arm
of the Department of Justice that these
situations with non prosecution
agreements are not covered by the CVRA
at the time because the CVRA
according to department policy does not
attach until a case is actually brought
now I understand that the judge had a
different view and I understand that the
judges view was the department policy
did not comply with the law and that's
the way our system works our system
works in that a judge can say what the
department policy is is not consistent
with the law now let me also point out
since then a few years ago Congress
amended the CVRA and
was amended explicitly to say that non
prosecution agreements would be in fact
covered and that is a good thing as I
said at my confirmation hearing
you know we expect a lot more
transparency if we had had more
transparency perhaps this case would
have gone differently I've laid out the
reasons why there were concerns about
providing all the details to the victims
before Epstein fled but the Department
of Justice has been very clear
throughout multiple presidential
administrations throughout multiple
attorneys general that the department's
position is that there was no violation
of the law would you make I saw you're
naming and Kruger with I'm Caitlin Cohen
CNN would you make this same agreement
today so these questions are always very
difficult because we now have 12 years
of knowledge and hindsight and we live
in a very different world today's world
treats victims very very differently
today's world does not allow some of the
victims thing that could have taken
place at trial 12 years ago today's
world understands that when interviewing
victims when a listening testimony that
testimony can be sometimes contradictory
that memories are difficult and so I
don't think we can say you know take a
case that is this bold and fully know
how it play out today I understand what
the victims say and I'm not here to try
to say that I can stand in their shoes
or that I can address their concerns I'm
here to say we did what we did because
we wanted to see
Epstein go to jail he needed to go to
jail he needed he needed he needed to go
to jail and that was that was the folks
so the victims of which we were aware
were part of this and and under the
agreement in the Southern District of
Florida the investigation ceased and
they had the opportunity to proceed it
Sibley that does not mean that the
investigation had to cease nationwide
and as we see today as we saw New York
investigations but certainly and
obviously have proceeded in other
districts so I have been I started one
of the first human trafficking task
forces at the Department of Justice I
have been aggressive prosecuting human
trafficking we stood we stepped in in
this case and we stopped a bad state
plea and so I understand from today's
perspective that people scratch their
heads and they say why here's the
question to ask how many other times
have you seen a US Attorney's Office
intervene in a state matter and say stop
the state plea because it is in
sufficient yes earlier this year it was
disclosed that they're going that
they're doing a review into how you and
other prosecutors in your office handled
this matter what is the status of that
what exactly are they looking at will
you
you submit to an interview even though
you're no longer with the Justice
Department and if they find any
misconduct will you resign first I don't
know what the status of that is I would
refer that to the Office of Professional
Responsibility I don't speak for them
I will clearly submit for an interview
even though I don't have to I think what
think he was important the Office of
Professional Responsibility will have
access to the whole record they will
have access to all the facts they all
have access to the FBI reports they'll
have access to the victim introduced
they can look at this matter in its
totality and and so I think it is
important that they proceed I will
gladly be part of it and and I think
what they will find is that the office
acted appropriately yummy shelfs
endureth PBS newshour as labor secretary
you've tried repeatedly to cut a program
that deals with with human trafficking
in the Labor Department by up to 80
percent going before Congress advocating
for that why should people trust you to
focus on human trafficking and protect
victims if you've done that and I'm like
a follow-up question so you're referring
to grants that go to foreign countries
for foreign country labor related work
as part of the budget every year those
grants have been removed as have other
grants for foreign countries and let me
just add as part of the budget every
year those grants are put right back in
by Congress this is what happens in
Washington and I fully suspect that
those grants will remain in this year
they're following sources of told me
that the president encouraged you to
hold this press conference can you speak
a little bit about what the president
told you ahead of this press conference
and whether you're you're here to give a
message to the president are you
fighting for your job or are you trying
to send a message to victims and if so
what is the message to the victim who
say they don't trust you anymore
so first I'm not about to talk about
conversations with the president and I'm
not here to send any signal to the
president I think it's important a lot
of questions were raised and I this has
reached the point that I
they could support to have a public
airing I think it's important that these
questions be asked and answered and and
asked to a message the victims the
messages you need to come forward I
heard this morning that another victim
came forward and made horrendous
horrendous allegations allegations that
should never happen to any woman much
less a young girl and has victims come
forward these cases can be brought and
they can be brought by the federal
government they can be brought by state
attorneys and they will be brought we
have seen in the last few years
cases brought against individuals that
got away with things for well over a
decade and you know it's important to
realize that people who are getting away
with these people were not going to jail
at all and we're aware of those
high-profile cases and we've seen as
victims come forward how the justice
system deals with it and so the message
to victims is come forward let me take a
few more
hi mr. secretary I'm Richard Madden
seeking me you just said victims need to
go sorry Richard Madden with CTV tell
you just said a moment ago the victims
should come forward but you still
haven't offered an apology to them why
is that so the victims should come
forward because the justice system needs
to hear from them and what the victims
went through is horrific what the
victims continued to go through is
horrific I've seen these videos I've
seen the interviews I'm sorry I've seen
the interviews on on television of these
victims and in their stories and and so
it's hard but I also think it's
important that we understand that the
men and women of my office going back to
2006 and 2007 and 2008 have spent their
career prosecuting these types of cases
and in their heart in our heart we were
trying to do the right thing for these
victims and so this is horrific this is
awful
each one of these cases
just devastating and saddening but I
also think it's important to realize
that the prosecutors were trying to do
the right thing sir
yeah Jeff Roe from Daily Mail are you
are you aware of alleged obstruction of
justice by mr. Epstein it seemed to be
been mentioned in that note in a BHEL
memo by new york prosecutors and did he
take every student to intimidate
prosecutors and if he did or harass
witnesses for witnesses if you did that
I can't I can't comment on the New York
case that that would not be appropriate
a pending your case in New York I can't
comment sir I'm curious who it mean
justice at Neal McKay one American news
who at main justice reviewed this case
or your decision and did you have any
interaction with robert muller at the
time so I shared a letter that I wrote
to one of Epstein's defense attorneys
and I shared that letter in part because
it shows much of the timeline it shows
how initially the the meetings that took
place were between the in July between
the first assistant that criminal chief
the Palm Beach the Palm Beach office
chief and the line attorney and two FBI
agents with absent attorneys you'll
notice that the initial meeting as
outlined in this letter who are all
three attorneys how they presented the
terms how Epstein's attorneys were
dissatisfied and asked for anything with
me how I subsequently with their
attorneys along with all the career
officials how at that meeting we then
invited the chief of the Child
Exploitation obscenity section from the
Department of Justice to travel down
because one of them you know one of the
things we wanted to make sure of was
that he had going back to the earlier
question about the ABA rule that we had
sufficient evidence to proceed ethically
and then it details a little bit on how
Epstein's counsels appealed the
decisions to Washington I'd refer you to
the record you know one of the really
disturbing things about
this case is there's a record here the
documents that I shared today we've
shared previously with media yet I've
seen no reference to any of these
documents in the perspective of some of
these prosecutors there's a record all
these documents are publicly available
and could have been pulled up by anyone
in this room and so and and so you know
there there is a record that will you
know I wasn't at main justice I do not
have a full list of the individuals that
that reviewed this matter at main
justice I can tell you the individuals
reference in this letter and and I would
refer you to the records I this was 12
years ago I do not have a full list of
individuals that review as well as the
record makes clear individuals from main
justice were involved fairly early on
and we're certainly aware of it and and
I think if you look at the record it
will become clear that our decisions
were appealed again and again to two
main justice so the deal that you
negotiated resulted in two things one is
that the case ended with mr. Epstein
pleading to state prostitution charges
and another thing that it did was I
immunized his co-conspirators so two
questions did you consider his victims
in that case to be prostitutes and why
did you immunize his co-conspirators so
the answer to were the victims
prostitutes no victims they were victims
end of story they were victims the
second part of that is in the purpose in
this case was to bring Epstein to jail
to put him behind bars and so there were
other individuals that may have been
involved that in any type of conspiracy
they're individuals around someone the
focus really is on the top player and
that's where our focus appropriately was
let me um let me also say something
because a lot has been said about
this 13 month when we proceeded the
expectation was that it would be an
18-month sentence and the expectation
was that it would be served in jail and
so this work release was complete yes
and I've been on record as far back as
2011 saying that it was not what was
bargained for and it was not what we
expected but this was a state court plea
and because it was a state court plea
the terms of confinement were under the
jurisdiction of the state of Florida and
so the outrage over that 13 month you
know getting to to leave jail is
entirely appropriate when we entered
into this we I at least fully thought
that he would be spending the time in
jail that's what we mean by someone
going to jail I was really appreciative
I'll tell you what if you answer the you
want if you ask me a question in Spanish
I will answer in Spanish is that fair I
was trying to get in new a trophy
darling it is Korean get the Senor where
our lockers here incredibly important
they kill fuera okay
yes well don't tell me again that e
connect total de Soto personal bikes and
no notice
okay 36 1 e por X so X see the very of
that is cool part second victim approval
last weakness and sofrito mucho mas e y
matado
say the lost interviews they'll all say
are you the mean they introduced and
released us BM pero la me have a mass
traffic ollie
titania said look upon the end go look
at the nearing the castle it's just a
question already forward what's your
message specifically to those who did
come forward and by you they can't look
the victims came forward and there were
several victims you know I believe that
in one of the filings the Department of
Justice talked to several of the victims
and some of the victims just didn't want
any any public notoriety other victims
have provided interviews and said they
felt left but down that they were left
out these are really hard cases the
prosecutors in my office and I were
focused on putting him in jail I
provided information from the career
tourney as to why there were concerns if
we went to trial and it became clear
that they were going to receive money if
he was convicted how that would impeach
their credibility and and today that
would proceed very differently because
the victim shaming is is just not
accepted but the circumstances of trials
and what juries would consider 12 years
ago was different and so these were the
judgments that were made I understand
that that individuals will look at these
judgments and say well maybe a different
judgment should have been made you know
you can always look at a play after the
fact and say should have been the safe
play or should you have gone for the big
score and ask which is the right outcome
but I provided these documents so that
you could hear from the prosecutors
themselves how these talk
was being wait sir November and if so
why don't you set the record straight on
the breakfast meeting that so media has
reached out to me over the years about
this I think it's very important the
Department of Justice is the entity that
is litigating all these matters and
quite honestly until until recently I
haven't commented on this since 2011
because I think it's important for the
United States to litigate cases through
the Department of Justice and if former
US Attorney's responded to media
inquiries about pending cases and this
is a pending case there was a live and
there still is a live civil matter
former US Attorney's responded to media
inquiries all the time we'd have havoc
in our justice system you can't have a
Department of Justice as a litigating
entity with US attorneys giving press
statements now your follow-up question
may be why am I talking today and the
answer is this has clearly reached a
level where I thought it was important
to have this kind of press conference to
take questions and to provide these
facts and these perspectives and I
understand that individuals may say this
was not enough but this is the way it
was viewed not only by me but by many
back in 2008 one thing yes you said that
the victims were not prostitutes but the
agreement was he was jailed for
prostitution charges not for Chavez for
the FIR of sex trafficking can you leave
the agreement the agreement was this was
a state here's here's blank by this is
hard this was a state case he was
arraigned he a state grand jury returned
a prostitution charge against him a
solicitation charge if I recall that was
a state grand jury he was allowed to
self surrender by the State Attorney's
Office
as a result of that single charge that
would have resulted in no jail time and
ultimately what the agreement did was
say you have to go back and you have to
plea to a more serious state charge that
requires jail time that requires
registration and under this agreement
you'll have a mechanism for restitution
but the agreement itself you know
ultimately the state of Florida and the
State Attorney's Office in Florida is a
separate sovereign the US attorney does
not determine how those offices run
themselves or what charges they bring I
do not consider the victims prostitutes
I think that is insulting to them these
were victims they were not just women
victims they were children victims mr.
Epstein left jail he's been a public
figure he's been a man about town he
hasn't seemed particularly contrite
about what he did what have you thought
when you've seen him you know what i've
thought is I keep reading newspaper
articles about pending investigations
here or there you know if if someone
does a Google search they'll see that
there were rumors of Investigations
going on for the last 10 years and New
York finally stood up and stood up and
they took one of those investigations
and they brought charges and in all
candor I wish it would have happened I'm
glad to see that it's happening now you
say you know he's a bad man and and he
needs to be put away and you know based
on additional allegations that I saw
this morning there are there multiple
jurisdictions whether federal or state
that he's gonna have to answer to a few
a few more a few more questions yes with
Miami Herald I wanted to ask him follow
through your answer the earlier question
about the potential co-conspirators were
you confident at the time that any
potential additional co-conspirators
didn't commit
sexual abuses against underage girls
like Epstein did even if it may have not
have been same scale because some of
those victims have accused others of
doing similar acts to them so let me see
how I can address your question without
running afoul of Department of Justice
guidelines if my office had been aware
of individuals who committed acts such
as as sexual abuse you know my office it
would not have been my position that
those individuals should have been part
of that kind of it's not even immunity
should not have been part of that
paragraph and so so I know that there
are a lot of rumors about who those
individuals who may or may not be I
think those rumors are misconstruing the
acts of the office with respect to that
particular paragraph one more question
Terry will you ever made aware at any
point your handling of this case mr.
Epstein was an intelligence so so so so
there has there has been reporting to
that effect and and let me say there's
been reporting to a lot of effects in
this case not just now but over the
years and and again I would you know I
would hesitate to take this reporting as
fact this was a case that was brought by
our office it was brought based on the
facts and and I look at that reporting
and others I can't address it directly
because of our our guidelines but I can
tell you that that a lot of reporting is
just going down the rabbit hole
a few a few more questions a few more
questions have you asked a question yet
okay how about that in front of you yes
sorry I'm trying to do it one question
for first
hi Katie Rodgers at the New York Times
I'm just wondering what makes you so
confident that the president is going to
continue to have you serve there have
been several advisors of his who he
stands he stands up for initially but
you're about at the level where he has
backed away before so what makes you so
confident so look I I am here to talk
about this case I'm doing my job if at
some point the president decides that I
am NOT the best person to do this job I
respect that that is his choice I serve
at the pleasure of the president I
thought yesterday he was kind and any
showed great support but we have to
remember we are here because we are part
of an administration that is creating
jobs that is creating growth that is
really transforming our economy and
focusing it on you know the the
forgotten man and woman and if at some
point he says look you know you're not
the right person for this right now or
or you know you're standing in the way I
respect that
these victims beyond you should come
forward that places a lot of burden on
children what else do you have to say
you've avoided addressing these these
people directly why so so she'd be clear
that is not all I said you know I think
if I recall and I obviously don't have a
transcript here but you know what I've
said previously is I have seen these
interviews and I can't
I generally can't begin to fathom what
these victims have been through I don't
think that anyone that has not been in
this situation can begin to fathom the
closest I can come is to think what
would I feel like if one of my girls was
going through this and I would be you
know I'm not sure I can say the way I
would feeling on television
but but even that is different than what
the victims themselves went through and
so the point I'm trying to make is
everything that the victims have gone
through in these cases is horrific and
and their response is entirely justified
at the same time I think it's important
to stand up for the prosecutors of my
former office and make clear that what
they were trying to do was help these
victims they should not be portrayed as
individuals that just didn't care
because they have spent a lifetime of
bringing cases like this they are
individuals who really really do yes hi
Nicki swab New York Post how much of
this do you think was at the scene
getting special treatment because of his
enormous enormous wealth and also
political connections so you know I've
heard a lot about that and if you go
through the record you will see that in
July he was presented with certain terms
and and I laid this out in a letter an
open letter that I wrote to address some
of these questions in 2011 and he was
presented with terms and the office
throughout this entire negotiation and
it took several months from July to what
December through these five months of
negotiations stop to those terms you go
to jail you register and you provide
restitution the original term was two
years the office ultimately agreed to 18
months register it had to be in effect
it had to be an offense where there was
registration because the world needed to
be unnoticed that he was a sexual
predator
and it had to be a situation where the
victims could seek restitution because
it wasn't just enough for him to go to
jail and let me also say you know I
restitution is also not enough you can
never put victims in the place they were
before they were victimized you can't
unwind history but restitution is
important thank you very much
legal team how powerful lawyers work and
they put pressure on you the different
pressure on DC it's someone at DOJ tell
you his his attorneys certainly filed
several appeals with main justice I will
again we state when the career attorneys
met with him they presented certain
terms and the office state routes those
terms throughout those terms did not
change the agreement did not change no
level of Appeal to main justice change
the terms of these initial points in
those agreements yes ma'am from Jane Doe
wanted to one of their requests is to
can they just meet with you you know
you're not apologizing today but would
you be willing to meet with them you
know that's a really that that's a
really good question
um this is currently in litigation and
so I I don't want to I don't want to
interfere with that litigation but let
me just say I have monitored this
litigation without I haven't monitored
day-to-day I have never pulled a full
record but I have watched it and I have
seen what these victims have gone
through and and whatever this litigation
is concluded I've always had an open
door policy and I've always welcomed the
opportunity to sit down and I think it'd
be really healthy for prosecutors
sometimes circle back and and really
hear about what happened because we all
have to learn you know one of the one of
the questions that came up at my
confirmation hearing was what would you
do differently and I alluded to this and
I said the world is much more
transparent we expect a lot more from
government we are a less trust in
society we can wonder whether that's
right or wrong but we are at less trust
in society today in part because our
culture expects transparency
and so to sit down and hear from victims
how this impacted them I think would be
healthy for prosecutors generally I
can't commit in this particular case
it's in litigation but I think that'd be
healthy for prosecutors Jenna thank you
very much